Hello again, this is
Dr. Brian Beatty, and
this is a histology
lecture on connective
tissue, muscle, nerve,
and applications.
In this lecture,
we're going to review
a lot of things we've
already discussed,
but we're going to
describe and compare
the general
morphology, functions,
locations of cartilage,
bone, and blood.
We'll also compare
and contrast the
characteristics
and those functions
and locations of
types of muscle.
We'll also discuss
the various
types of nervous
tissue, which we
haven't really
discussed much yet,
and we'll discuss
especially
histogenesis and
the development
of different
types of tissue
again as a review
there are specialized
connective tissues
right we know as
cartilage bone and
blood and among
cartilage there's
hyaline cartilage
elastic cartilage and
fiber cartilage and
bun there's spongy
and compact bone
the general summary
cartilage can be
characterized as firm and
durable typically that's
usually to deal with
mechanical stresses
the matrix right the
extracellular matrix
is typically 60 to 80
percent water it is
dominated by type 2
collagen fibers and
elastic fibers depending
again on the cartilage
site there's a high
concentration of
glycosaminoglycans as
well as proteoglycans
cartilage tends not
to be a vast tends not
to be vascular right
so it's avascular and
it's also generally
not innervated much.
It's involved in
the development
and growth of
long bones, the
endochondral
ossification situations.
Chondrocytes are the
cells that are found
within lacunae, which
you can see on the
right side of this
image, and it is covered
by something called
perichondrium,
which is a connective
tissue layer outside.
There are three
types of cartilage,
hyaline, which is
the most common,
you find it in
the joint surfaces
as well as of
other places,
and elastic cartilage,
which we find especially
in the ears and larynx,
and fiber cartilage,
which we find in
intervertebral discs
some the ***** symphysis
and cranial sutures
cartilage hyaline means
glassy and hyaline
cartilages can be
found in joints as well
as epiphyseal plates it
is tends to be fairly
homogeneous in the
structure and also come
somewhat transparent
or semi-transparent
uh its function well
is generally there for
support and reinforcement
it's a relatively
resilient cushion and
resists repetitive
stresses they tend to
be located in articular
surfaces of movable
joints otherwise
known as synovial joints
the walls of large
respiratory passages
such as the trachea and
bronchi and the
epiphyseal plates of bones
this kind of cartilage
tends to be lost
in osteoarthritis
as well as highland
cartilage is found in
the cost of cartilages
and can calcify it
with age and of course
is affected by somatotropin
which is coming
from the anterior
pituitary another type
of cartilage is
elastic cartilage and
this is similar to
hyaline cartilage except
there are far far more
elastic fibers and
they tend to function
to maintain shape
and structure and are
very very flexible
they tend to be located
in places that you'd
expect them to be
for needing to be
flexible such as the
external ear, the epiglottis,
or even the upper
respiratory tract.
Major types of cartilage.
Fiber cartilage
is like hyaline
cartilage, but it's
got dense connective
tissue within it,
right? So it is a high
tensile strength and
ability to absorb
compressive shocks,
and these tend to
be found in places
where you would need
that, such as the
***** symphysis or
intervertebral discs.
and to review bone very
briefly we know that
it's a calcified matrix
right extracellular
matrix becomes
calcified in terms of
its function well it
supports and protects
organs it provides levers
and attachment sites
for muscles it stores
calcium ions and
other minerals it
actually also stores fat
within it inside bone
marrow and of course
red marrow is the place
where hematopoiesis
otherwise blood cell
formation happens.
And it has a complex
structure, right? This
is one of the things
that we can see here
on the left side, that
many bones have either
some composite version
of spongy bone or
trabecular bone on
the inside and compact
bone on the outside.
And that compact bone
has layers to it,
right? So lamellations.
And as a bone becomes
more mature, it forms
reversion systems that
are situations which
osteoclasts, which
are the bone absorbing
um cells that they
destroy it dissolve it
those osteoclasts
leave channels and then
those channels are
filled in with new bone
formed by osteoblasts
and of course blood
vessels and nerves uh
filled in those spaces
as well and as those
channels become
more have more layers
of bone grown in them
those osteoblasts gets
stuck in the layers
of that those are
called osteocytes then
so here is a nice
histology image of those
three types of cells
right so there are
osteocytes those are
the cells that are stuck
within the bone matrix
there are osteoblasts
on the edges of them
that are forming new
bone matrix itself and
they're also classed
like this one gigantic
one sort of in
the bottom middle of
the image that's all
purple that's a multinucleated
large cell right
and that is there to
dissolve uh matrix
there are two major
types of bone tissue
that we see this compact
bone otherwise known
as dense bone or lamellar
bone and trabecular
bone which tends to
be made of spicules
and that cancels
bone is also known as
spongy or light bone and
you can see it on the
right one quick brief
uh summary about
blood histology we're
going to get Again, this
is just the tip of
the iceberg. You're
going to get a lot
more on this at another
date, but just so that
you can remind yourself
about the function of
blood as a specialized
connective tissue,
it is there for the
transportation of
oxygen, carbon dioxide,
also metabolites
and hormones, right?
It also distributes
heat around the body.
In that way, it regulates
body temperature.
And by moving all
those things around, it
also maintains the
acid base and osmotic
balance of the blood in
the rest of the body.
now there are a number
of different cells
involved in blood
um of course we know
erythrocytes right those
are red blood cells
there are lots of them
they're avat they're
anucleated right they
have no nucleus um we
also have plasma right
and that's mostly
water and proteins and
some of the solutes
and then uh what's
called the buffy coat
right the the tiny
percentage of whole blood
but the important
things like platelets as
well as leukocytes and
of course platelets
are these little tiny
things and leukocytes
are otherwise known as
white blood cells and
they come in lots
of forms neutrophils
monocytes lymphocytes
basophils and eosinophils
a brief review of
muscle tissue you know
of course that the
main function of muscle
is to create movement
but also in the
production of heat right
there are three major
types of muscle tissue
there are skeletal
muscle cardiac muscle
and smooth muscle
all skeletal muscles
are attached to bones
largely not always but
mostly they are long
multi-nucleated
cylindrical cells for the
most part they are
voluntary meaning you
have a voluntary control
over them and they
are striated and that
means they have a
series of lines visible
on them when you look
at them histologically
and those lines are
delineated something
called sarcomeres And
sarcomeres are these
lines of parallel
proteins that link and
unlink from each other,
and those are known
as actin and myosin.
Here's a beautiful
view of that striation,
right, of long
axis of a muscle.
where you can see
those dark and light
bands basically
relating to where myosin
is visible as dark
bands, or where you
don't see it, where
the light band is.
The type of muscle
tissue that we've
been talking about
is cardiac muscle.
And of course, you
know that cardiac
muscle is either
one or two nuclei,
where are uni or
binucleated, and these
tend to be
branching, right? and
they can branch
actually several times.
And of course,
cardiac muscle
is only found in
the heart, and
it's known as
the myocardium.
These do have
striations to them,
right? Because there
are intercalated
discs and filaments
pulling on
each other in an
organized fashion.
But these, of course,
are involuntary and
controlled by the
autonomic nervous system.
Our third and last
type of muscle tissue,
of course, is smooth
muscle. And remember,
those smooth muscle
cells are spindle
-shaped, and they have
a central nucleus.
They don't have any
striations, right,
so there's no
sarcomere involved. In
fact, the iactin and
myosin fibers are
linking in sort of not
a random order, but
a much more set of
oblique orientations.
Like cardiac
muscle, these are
involuntary and
controlled by
the autonomic
nervous system.
And these, of
course, are found
in the walls of
hollow organs
and also in
blood vessels.
and the neuromuscular
junction which is
usually very unique and
specialized in cardiac
muscles as well as
skeletal muscles the
neuromuscular junction
here is is distinctive but
in these little
varicosities and lastly
histology wouldn't be
complete without discussing
nervous tissue you're
going to get a lot
more on nervous tissue
during the neuroanatomy
course in the spring
semester but just to
give it at least a
little bit of attention
since we haven't really
discussed it much
nervous tissue is one
of the four tissue types
right and nervous tissue
is either basically
you're discussing
neurons or glial cells
right so neurons those
are the typical nerves
that we think about
these are cells that
have axons and dendrites
they can be unipolar
bipolar or multipolar
that just is a
determination about how
much branching there is
involved and of course
They can serve sensory
or motor functions,
or they can actually
function in something
called an interneuron,
which are just neurons
between other neurons.
When you also have the
glial cells, and of
course, glial cells
within the central nervous
system are known
as astrocytes or
oligodendrocytes or microglia
or epindeminal cells.
These are all cells
that are mostly
there for support
of those neurons.
And in the peripheral
nervous system,
we usually think of
these in the context
of Schwann cells
or satellite cells.
and one more comment
make sure you fully
understand this i'm sure
this is already well
drilled in your head
is the central nervous
system of course is
the brain and spinal
cord and the peripheral
nervous system
is the cranial and
spinal nerves themselves
so after a brief summary
of general histology
that we've had right
i just thought it'd
be worth mentioning
something about
development right so
you've heard this already
quite a bit but early
on during development
of course you have
gastrulation right
this is the super
important part of your life
that you don't remember
right but this is
when those tissues
differentiate right so
of course we all started
at just fertilized
egg right um but
everything is determined
on this right this
moment so as those
tissues start to
differentiate this is when
you can actually have
problems with development
right major doings
during the second
month development is
when you've already
gotten all those four
prime tissue types
developing right in
fact by that stage you
also have major organs
in place of course by
adulthood way later
on right by adulthood
many of these tissues
even stop regenerating
right so you might
maintain some
populations of stem
cells um to do some
repair for example
in the epithelium and
stuff like that but
many tissues don't have
many stem cells left
at all and eventually
they will stop
repairing themselves
And this is
probably what you
get as close to
the concept of
dying from old
age than anything.
Because, again, these
cells, once they stop
being able to repair
themselves, as normal
wear and tear happens
and damage happens,
things stop being
able to repair
themselves. So,
for example, with
increasing age, much
greater increasing
age, you get
thinner epithelia
because you can't
replace those cells.
You have reductions
in collagen, so joints
and other things
become less well
-connected and therefore
mechanically weaker.
You have bones,
muscles, and nervous
tissues start to
atrophy because,
again, they can't
replace the cells
that die from
inadvertent situations.
You sometimes also
will develop poor
nutrition and
poor circulation
because, again,
those cells that help
you maintain those
things can't replace
themselves or
repair themselves.
And, of course,
because of a lot of
these things that
would control and
stop uncontrolled
growth, you have an
increased chance of
developing cancer.
To look at this
in a maybe more
granular way, right,
we also need to
think about
histogenesis, right, the
actual formation
of those tissues.
So to recall,
right, we've talked
about this, and
I'm sure Dr.
Slunas has shared
some of this.
the trilaminar embryo
right the ectoderm
mesoderm and endoderm
layered little little
fishy looking guy
right starts out with
those three layers the
ectoderm the outermost
part right this has
actually two different
sort of portions you
know that very clearly
divided right but
the surface ectoderm
this is this becomes
the epidermis and its
derivatives like the
cornea the lens epithelium
enamel on teeth,
that's actually also
from surface ectoderm,
your internal ear,
the adenohypothesis,
right, the
part of the pituitary,
the mucosa of
the oral and ****
cavities, those
also come from
surface ectoderm.
There's also something
called neuroectoderm,
right, and these are
specialized cells
that form the central
nervous system
and the peripheral
nervous system. Again,
those two are also
coming from ectoderm.
And then, of course,
then we have the
mesoderm, right, which
is that middle layer
and that mesoderm
oh boy does it may
become a lot of things
right it becomes all
the connective tissue
it becomes all the
muscle tissue it
becomes the heart the
blood vessels the
lymphatics and all many
of the major organs
right the spleen the
kidneys the ******
even the mesothelium
right there's a layer
of epithelium like
tissue that's that's
separating the um
celoma cavity organs
from each other
and of course the
adrenal cortex
and our last layer
right endoderm that's
the innermost layer
this is giving rise to
a large number of
tissues that maybe you
hadn't thought about
right besides the
obvious thing like
the alimentary canals
epithelium that's
otherwise known as the gi
tract right the lining
of the tract but
many tissues derive
themselves from that
and includes things
like the liver and the
pancreas, and even the
gallbladder, right?
Those are imaginations
from that layer.
The lining of the
urinary bladder and
most of the urethroid
also come from this.
The respiratory
system epithelium also
derives from this,
because remember, it's
an extension of the
primordial gut tube.
The thyroid,
parathyroid, and thymus,
those are all
derivations from many
of these same tissues
of the pharynx.
The tonsils, same
thing, same story.
And even epithelium
of the tympanic cavity
and auditory tubes
are also extensions
of the layers that are
coming from the oral
mucosa and the beginning
of the pharynx.
That was just a
review of a lot of our
histology, trying to
link it to development
and also the adult
anatomy that you're
seeing. But you
also should review
these things is really
there's some great
summaries and uh
chapters in the histology
textbooks that are
out there including
first aid so i hope
you take a look
at those to get some
further information
lastly i'd really like
to get some feedback
on this this summary
review sort of lecture
that sort of starts
hinting at things like
nervous tissue this
is something that's
maybe a holdover from
the past and maybe not
necessary and i want
to make sure that i'm
i'm making the best
use of at the time,
so please give me some
feedback. Thank you.